good evening and thank you for joining
us for this eight news now special
feeding the las vegas valley i'm kirsten
joyce and i'm christian goss that is
according to feeding america it's
estimated that one in every nine
nevadans is suffering from food
insecurity not only that last year
nevada came in eighth place nationally
among states with the highest projected
overall food and security and tonight we
are working to define and tackle this
complex problem so what does food
insecurity mean it's described as not
having access to sufficient food to live
a healthy life for many it's the result
of financial problems and or lack of
knowledge of healthy and nutritious food
choices food insecurity can even lead to
chronic diseases and mental health
issues and now that the kova 19 pandemic
is easing and inflation is unfortunately
surging more people need assistance
tonight eight news now will show you
resources and provide knowledge to
tackle food insecurity and while not
knowing where your next meal is coming
from may not be a current problem for
you we will also share ways for you to
stretch your dollar and preserve food
will hunger ever end here in the valley
that's the question we post to a number
of different non-profits in southern
nevada well one of which is catholic
charities they help individuals and
families with a number of services
including emergency shelter immigration
and refugee assistance as well as
fighting hunger and improving nutrition
for those in need and we can tell you
the need has skyrocketed over the past
few months
it's hard to imagine being without
something as simple as food but many
people who come to catholic charities of
southern nevada arrive here because
these and other basic needs aren't being
met
these days people are struggling to
survive says president and deacon thomas
roberts we've seen increases in numbers
of first-timers at our food pantry
people that are frankly a little
embarrassed a little frustrated and a
little anxious about being here deacon
roberts says that's why catholic
charities of southern nevada exists to
provide help and hope roberts raised his
own family in las vegas he's been the
president and ceo of catholic charities
for the past decade when we give of
ourselves to others it allows us to make
more room in our heart for generosity
and compassion right now 2500 seniors
are getting food through ccsn's meals on
wheels program that's up from 800
seniors just a few years back and they
still have 500 seniors on a waiting list
every day the community meal is packed
it's a free hot freshly served meal at
10 a.m offered to anyone in need as well
as 125 families who come in each day to
the hands of hope community food pantry
it provides a pre-packaged box of food
items including fresh produce canned and
frozen foods
sometimes as the month goes on that
number grows because people simply run
out of food do you think we're ever
going to be able to tackle hunger here
in the valley you know after being here
for 30 years and being in the gaming
industry for a long time and then being
a catholic church for 10 years i often
think that we probably consume per
capita more food in this valley maybe
than any place else in the world
and it sometimes frustrates me that we
see so many people with food insecurity
but he says they will continue to do
their part help as many people as they
can a stewardship model of time talents
and treasure through donations
partnerships and volunteers we're going
to build and continue the renovation at
the campus to grow infrastructure for
more meals
talking to the governor who i saw over
the weekend our congressional delegation
about the need for more public funding
and then private funding
incidentally catholic charities has very
low overhead 90 cents of every dollar
donated goes directly to helping people
right now the nonprofit is in need of
canned protein canned vegetables peanut
butter cereal pasta and pasta sauce
well catholic charities isn't the only
place in town looking for donations i
spoke to lisa segler the director of
strategic initiatives at three square
food bank she says the need is big in
the valley and they work every day to
close that meal gap well three square
food bank offers a variety of food
programs for all ages including
groceries home delivery and on-site meal
program due to inflation segler says
there is an increase in senior citizens
at the distribution a helpful hand that
would not be possible she says without
the support from the community
everyone is part of the solution and
really reaches out to be a part of this
but everything from a canned food drive
all the way to we have a robust food
rescue program that goes to local
restaurants and
grocery stores to rescue that food and
then we then turn around and safely
distribute that food into the community
well she adds that donations come from
everywhere and three square is thankful
for every single one now if you want to
help or receive help you can contact
three square
well there are also drive through
distribution operated by three squares
partners all over the valley just like
this one here put on by the consulate of
mexico
in las vegas on sixth street and hoover
on average about 250 people drop off
food here every single day they
distribute that food on the second and
the fourth friday of each month one
thing to note it's important to get
there early as many people do line up
and are only allowed a certain amount of
food now we have a list of all the sites
across the valley on our website right
now eight newsnow dot com
another program that offers services to
people living in southern nevada
regardless of religious affiliation is
lutheran social services of nevada they
are open to anyone who needs the
assistance right now their largest
population seniors
this gentleman didn't wish to be
interviewed but allowed us to follow him
as he picked up food items from lutheran
social services of nevada he is one of
more than 600 households currently
getting food from the nonprofit a number
that has increased since the pandemic
and continues to do so during this time
of record inflation
any family or individual can walk in or
schedule an appointment to pick up
groceries twice a month monday through
thursday from nine in the morning until
one
all you need is your photo id provide
your current address and fill out a few
forms nutrition services manager jesus
martinez most of our clients are seniors
and you know
statistics show that 7 out of 10 seniors
are hungry here in vegas so we don't
want that to happen we live in one of
the richest countries of the world
and there's no reason for someone to be
hungry
with seniors on a fixed income their
dollars no longer stretch as far as they
used to and they don't want seniors
choosing between buying medication
paying rent or having food on the table
martinez says in addition to the food
pantry which three square food bank
helps stock lutheran social services
partners with two churches located in
low-income neighborhoods to provide hot
meals to seniors every day we also have
two senior meals locations at different
areas holy spirit and living hope
so where people get a hot meal every day
so
they could congregate with other seniors
don't be isolated at home there was also
an open air market with fresh vegetables
fruit and other items and a nutritional
education kitchen offering a six-week
course on healthy eating and cooking i
don't think on jesus that will ever
solve the problem of food insecurity in
the valley
no but it takes an agency like us to
help
as many people
lutheran services also kicked off a
one-of-a-kind online food pantry called
digimart just prior to pandemic digimart
allows clients to shop by logging into
the online food pantry system choose
what they want or they can even use the
desktop kiosks it is currently on pause
but will start back up again sometime in
the near future christian
while food insecurity may be harmful to
people of all ages it can be especially
devastating to children kids suffering
from food insecurity are more likely to
repeat a grade in elementary school
experience developmental impairments in
areas like language and motor skills and
have more social and behavioral problems
now to combat this the clark county
school district provides free meals to
break for breakfast and lunch now that's
happening until the end of the 2025
school year and is funded by federal
nutrition programs
a las vegas woman set out to make a
change right here in our community by
offering something no one else was free
vegan food yeah this idea caught on and
now the lost vegan food bank is dishing
out help in the form of produce and
greatness well our very own heather
mills takes us to their distribution
site serving up a niche market
according to one website citing the
number of vegans vegan restaurants and
vegan groups nevada is number one in the
u.s in fact there's 14 000 people who
follow the las vegas vegans facebook
page vegan food staples they tend to be
less expensive than meat but with the
price of everything going up there's a
market
and there's certainly a need
whether by choice or doctor ordered
veganism is growing in popularity but in
a desert where growing food can be
somewhat of a challenge and with rising
food prices a lot of folks need the
extra help one regular box there was
more of a need in the community because
of
because of people experiencing
the side effects of covid and
the economy the initial idea was mine
but the rest has been a complete
collaborative effort of all of our staff
volunteers the concept of the vegan food
bank bloomed and really began taking
shape at the end of 2020. our goal from
the start has been to feed our community
food with high nutritional value and
then our boxes are full of produce dry
goods and shelf safe items multi-grain
hearty healthy items and no animal
products we are a vegan establishment so
no meat no dairy no eggs no honey
partnering with united movement
organized kindness and purple carrot
this grassroots organization is really
taking seed hi there welcome first name
please they've already packed and
distributed thousands and thousands of
boxes of food with distributions
happening the second and fourth saturday
of the month
they're generating community support and
forming bonds with one another it's
great putting the boxes together meeting
fellow vegans talking about food recipe
and just supporting supporting the being
a vegan jim larson runs a halfway house
in town he heard about the food pantry
from one of his residents this is the
first time they've been over here but i
think it's great that they're having
quality food
and being able to because nutrition is a
major major part of anybody's recovery
and part of mindy portinga's journey to
give back as the founder of lost vegan
food bank we do it because we care about
our community
well the last vegan food bank is working
to obtain grants in order to increase
its distributions
well as we worked on the special feeding
the las vegas valley we both found out
so much about food insecurity a green a
grim statistic one million nevadans skip
meals or eat less due to unaffordable
prices well up next my story of a las
vegas man when he consumes in a month as
he chooses between paying the bills and
eating
plus the most important thing you should
be doing to save money on your grocery
bill stay with us here
who loves the 87 000 new irs agents that
senator catherine cortez masto just
authorized
instead of reducing spending or
simplifying taxes cortes masto again
dramatically increased government
spending and inflation
she voted against making them focus on
the wealthy cortes masto spends then six
her massive irs on middle-class families
to pay for it club for growth action is
responsible for the content of this ad
in nevada we have a lot of hard-working
people and a whole lot of sunshine and
catherine cortez masto she gets it she's
done more than anyone to keep nevada's
solar energy industry growing katherine
knows investing in clean energy creates
jobs
brings new businesses to our state and
helps nevada family to save money on
utility bills
now that's what i call a bright idea a
really bright idea i'm catherine cortez
masto and i approve this message
my name is elise and this is baby orion
he's seven weeks today baby's bounty has
been wonderful with having a supply of
formula for those in need since we
launched our diaper bank may 20th of
2020 we've distributed 1.5 million
diapers 3.5 million wipes to over 25 000
of southern nevada's chinese residents
just having the diapers that the baby
needs it's great
[Music]
finley supports baby's bounty in helping
at risk families with young children
we've been looking for new ways to help
spread the word about how great it is to
be a member at silver state schools
credit union so i asked my friend
mercedes to help out members get awesome
perks like great rates cool benefits and
personalized service wow mercedes that's
really loud well yeah you asked me to
spread the word
i was thinking maybe you could say it on
the radio oh
yeah that makes sense
become a member today and have a
financial partner for life
we're the lifelong local and we're the
welcome wagon in 1972 we saw our very
first patient ever since we've been
expanding our services locations and our
team to bring quality healthcare to you
our neighbors
for 50 years we've called las vegas home
and we couldn't be prouder
thank you for trusting us with your help
southwest medical 50 years of community
care
[Music]
as we continue to dive into the struggle
of food insecurity here in southern
nevada there's one thing we can't ignore
and that is inflation it's continuing to
impact families all across the valley
forcing many to seek new ways to
purchase food it's a grim reality that
sometimes can't be solved until you see
the challenge firsthand
i haven't eaten a decent meal in like a
year robert wagner moved to las vegas
from chicago three years ago seeking a
better life but now he says he's down on
his luck chap is cutting our pay and
i won't pay for rent anymore and
and ebt has been cut and all my benefits
are gone so
it's very hard to survive according to
the usda a single adult spends about 411
dollars a month on groceries the average
american spends on average of 8.6
percent of their disposable income on
food with inflation causing costs to go
up wagner says it's a struggle by the
end of the month i'm already broke so
i'm starving you know i'm not i'm not
eating for about a week you know yeah so
i gotta really
plan my food out you know and don't eat
as much as i want to eat
small businesses like this one near
arville and flamingo are key to
residents like wagner because they
accept ebt or wic from their customers
store manager sherman habibian says it's
a win-win for everyone it's a source of
revenue for the store and the other part
is to make it a little bit more
convenient for the people that are on
wicker ebt
to be able to come over here and pick up
some of the necessities that they do
need
with the government's assistance wagner
says he can pick up some of the basic
items to get by while he continues to
seek better job opportunities i get free
from here you know i get little tv
dinners
stretching our dollars when grocery
shopping if you're not the type to clip
coupons although that's certainly one
way to make your money work for you
we've got a number of other suggestions
for saving at the grocery store all
thanks to our money savings expert
andrea warrock
meal planning is the most important
thing we should all be doing to save
money look at your schedule do you have
a business meeting do your kids have a
birthday party you're not going to be
cooking for those nights or
or meals so then you don't have to buy
extra groceries savings expert and mom
of two andrea warwick says this allows
you to be specific about what you buy
and nothing ends up in the trash
when possible buy frozen over fresh
especially when it comes to produce even
frozen fish is cheaper than fresh fish
this allows you to you know not worry
about that fruit or fresh vegetable that
you bought spoiling if you don't have a
chance to eat it before it goes bad
grocery stores make 50 percent of their
profits on grocery shoppers impulse
purchases you can eliminate those by
sticking to your list or avoid
temptation altogether by ordering with a
service now even though there are fees
associated warwick says you can cut
those delivery fees by looking for
coupon codes sign up for free trials or
go to a site like couponfollow.com
they had deals such as 20 off your first
order of 35 at instacart 15 off orders
at kroger grocery stores
and as for going out to eat if you have
a warehouse club membership buy gift
cards to your favorite restaurants in
bulk that way you can get 20 savings
right off the bat and of course
christian another way to save on
groceries simply saving your food not
wasting it that's a great idea well we
clear up the confusion around product
dating labels which is responsible for
20 percent of food waste
also the cost to feed our fur babies is
also on the rise we'll check in with a
local pet pantry keep it here
we're the lifelong local and we're the
welcome wagon in 1972 we saw our very
first patient ever since we've been
expanding our services locations and our
team to bring quality healthcare to you
our neighbors
for 50 years we've called las vegas home
and we couldn't be prouder
thank you for trusting us with your help
southwest medical 50 years of community
care
washington's reckless irresponsible
spending is costing nevadans plenty and
senator catherine cortez masto has also
voted for spending that's even more
reckless allowing coveted relief checks
to go to convicted criminals in prison
including the boston marathon bomber a
michigan sex abuser murderers and drug
dealers and voting to let covet checks
go to illegal immigrants tell senator
cortez masto to start voting against
reckless and wasteful spending to stop
inflation
from the depths of the dollar loan
center arena in henderson nevada and
accessed exclusively on the world wide
web at don't be broke.com
i present to you
the loan approval
machine
[Music]
apply online adobe brogue.com
one in every eight nevadans face hunger
that's why findlay automotive is proud
to support the just one project thank
you tyler the just one project is
nevada's largest volunteer organization
monthly we distribute over 600 000
pounds of groceries we have 13 mobile
distribution locations around the valley
so we are able to get healthy food to
those who need it most we know that it
takes just one person to make a
difference to volunteer or learn more
please visit thejustoneproject.org
here at silver state schools credit
union we do things differently than
other financial institutions
we are a not-for-profit member-owned
credit union
which means you the member benefit from
better rates and excellent member
service
and we make it easy for anyone to become
a member
so what are you waiting for become a
member today and have a financial
partner for life
[Music]
according to the usda 30 to 40 percent
of our food supply is wasted a big
contributor expiration dates 20 percent
of food tossed simply because of
consumer confusion well many of us
believe food product dates of best buy
or sell by are federally regulated and
indicate the point after which the food
is no longer safe to eat but that's not
the case more now from a las vegas
grocery chain on how to preserve food
it's hard to think that hunger is
happening right in our backyards and the
contradiction is 40 percent of food that
we produce in the united states goes to
waste a briana martindale with smith's
groceries says the hunger problem in
nevada is alarming for children the
numbers are worst if we dig even deeper
one in six
children in the state of nevada don't
know where their next meal is coming
from one solution martindale says is
rethinking those expiration dates we see
on each food item we purchase
she says expiration dates are not
regulated and that can cause many items
to get tossed in the trash it doesn't
mean that that food is bad that is just
the debt the date set forth by that
vendor saying this may be the best
use by date for peak quality and peak
taste some options experts say you
should consider take those items with
near expiration dates and freeze them
also if your fresh produce have a
blemish peel the skin and get creative
with recipes
smith's groceries is joining the fight
with their zero hunger zero waste policy
an effort to eliminate food waste in the
company by 2025. you grab an apple and
it has a blemish on it what we will do
is mark that produce down we put a few
items in what we call a red bag and put
on a red bag rack if it doesn't get sold
we donate it to the food bank like three
square
your pets could certainly be feeling the
effects of inflation with the rising
costs of food medical and general pet
care there are resources the nevada spca
has a pet pantry that provides food for
dogs and cats it is donation driven if
you have any cans or bags of food your
pet may not prefer please donate them
well groups most affected by food
insecurity single mother households and
households with income below poverty
level that points to certain areas in
our valley after the break why where you
live plays a factor in the fight against
hunger
we're the lifelong local and we're the
welcome wagon in 1972 we saw our very
first patient ever since we've been
expanding our services locations and our
team to bring quality healthcare to you
our neighbors
for 50 years we've called las vegas home
and we couldn't be prouder
thank you for trusting us with your
health
southwest medical 50 years of community
care
leaders find solutions politicians are
part of the problem take catherine
cortez masto and adam laxalt cortez
masto co-sponsored a bill capping
insulin costs adam laxalt called a plan
that caps costs reckless no surprise
laxalt is personally invested in big
drug companies when they make money he
makes money that's the difference
catherine cortez masto is lowering the
cost of drugs adam laxalt sells out and
cashes in smp is responsible for the
content of this ad celebrate under the
stars at the collaboration center
foundation's night own blanc alice
september 28th at its las vegas ranch
campus this magical evening benefits
locals living with autism and other
developmental and physical disabilities
of all ages proceeds will go directly to
critical services these families need to
thrive reserve your tickets now for
night on blanc sponsored by our
community pride partners findlay
automotive group southwest medical part
of optum care and silver state schools
credit union
here at silver state schools credit
union we do things differently than
other financial institutions
we offer free financial literacy tools
to help you make smart financial
decisions now and in the future
and we invest in southern nevada by
giving back to schools and to deserving
charities
[Music]
so what are you waiting for become a
member today and have a financial
partner for life
[Music]
my name is elise and this is baby orion
he is seven weeks today baby's bounty
has been wonderful with having a supply
of formula for those in need since we
launched our diaper bank may 20th of
2020 we've distributed 1.5 million
diapers 3.5 million wipes to over 25 000
of southern nevada's chinese residents
just having the diapers that the baby
needs it's great
finley supports baby's bounty in helping
at-risk families with young children
well tonight we are shedding light on
hunger and food insecurity david charns
looks at where it is in our valley by
zip code
every zip code there are neighbors that
we have here in our valley who struggle
with hunger hunger has no barriers in
the las vegas valley really many of us
are within two paychecks away of not
having the money that we need to buy the
food that we need jody tyson with three
square says data like unemployment
income even if more people rent than own
a home can lead them in the right
direction we can accurately predict the
number of our neighbors in each of our
zip codes that struggle with food
insecurity the latest map from three
square from before the pandemic shows no
zip code untouched 89106 that's north of
downtown with the highest percent of
those who are food insecure with 89101
just to the east at number two areas
with higher incomes like summerlin and
parts of henderson are vulnerable as
well while where you live may be an
indicator money is the real barometer
when the pandemic hit three square was
servicing some 400 thousand people it
really helps us drive resources like the
food you're seeing pack today directly
to those zip codes so that we can close
that gap on food insecurity i'm david
charns 8 news now
fighting hunger involves all of us and
our parent company nexstar is teaming up
with feeding america that's right scan
this qr code and it will take you to our
website thank you for joining us
[Music]